in the eu the number of credit cards
carried per person is point eight
and not even one per person u.s is four
which is like a debit card for your bank
just a bank transfer card that's all you
have yeah yeah we just use debit cards
yes that's what i'm talking about yeah
yeah but then in that case there's no
there's no debt right i mean at worst
someone might have an overdraft but um
no it's just secure transport of money
yeah i don't know i genuinely don't
understand the point of credit cards i i
don't get it i've had people try to
explain it to me and i'm like i don't
get why i'd want that well why well i
will spend your own money you know you
can spend somebody else but i will tell
them but but i will tell you
amongst people
who who have money
uh uh uh
you know you'll see that guys who have
real real money they will not use a
debit card
and not because they're not using the
debit card because they don't have the
cash
they use the kind of a credit card that
you pay at the end of the month not the
kind of a credit card that you're like
hey you know i'm gonna you pay off you
know people have credit cards that they
pay at the end of the month every month
we have you know one of our credit cards
we pay i don't know what the numbers
every month four five hundred thousand
dollars per month that we pay off
because it's like a business credit card
but we have to pay it every month it's
not rolling right
and the reason for that is protection
because you don't want your debit card
number out there that's what you don't
want because that can be hacked into
your
cash where the money's at so that's the
only argument against
debit is to use credit that you pay at
the end of the month what you're saying
is which makes a lot of sense is the
credit card to just use and pile up the
debt i pay it off i paid off i paid off
and that's kind of the culture i mean i
got caught up in that in my early 20s i
was in that 49 000 and it was a mess it
took me a minute to pay that thing off i
had a choice between bk and paying it
off and eventually paid it off but it
was not an easy transition to go through
it so
um can i add to this yeah the um you
touched on it like i don't understand
the purpose of credit score i talked
about you know this all the time where i
don't really i mean i have a good credit
score not going to lie it's 800 whatever
but it's like
if i'm more concerned with my net worth
yeah than my credit score that's what
people like you talked about the the
problem that we're having in america is
the credit score and credit cards has
been gamified i'm getting points i'm
getting miles i get to travel i get to
travel for free i uh who's the guy catch
me if you can the movie that leonardo
dicaprio played um
i'm escaping his name but the uh great
guy he's basically saying you ready
abigail frank abigail exactly he was
saying you have to have a credit card
that's the only thing prevent fraud if
sometimes someone takes your debit card
and takes you know 10 grand off of it
that's gonna be a lot more difficult
getting it back because that's your
money versus the credit card you call
the credit card you call it in so there
is this thing thing with that
back to the credit card situation i
don't know if you're aware of this tom
so i talk about the four c's of debt
everyone has to deal with this we've got
credit cards you've got car loans yep
you've got college right student debt
and the big one is cribs aka mortgages
if you obviously if you buy your house
right you know what you're doing but a
lot of people feel like they have to buy
they buy more house and they can afford
and they get into this mortgage debt
situation that's we've all seen the
cribs on mtv payment base lifestyle
exactly can i go how much you're gonna
do but here's the interesting thing
about credit cards credit cards during
the pandemic
was the only of those four that went
down 2.1 billion dollars for credit card
debt were erased exactly so people were
buying so people were buying cribs
people were buying more cars we all saw
that used car prices have skyrocketed
when has that ever happened
right and then people still keep going
to college but
uh credit card debt went down by 13 now
we had we had this big spike of up 13
because it went down because everyone's
sitting at home no one's traveling other
than zoo be traveling around the world
and everyone's just sitting home they're
they're getting stimulus checks they're
getting unemployment checks they're like
all right [ __ ] it i'll pay down this
credit card then so that's the reason
that it's escalated so if you look at
the credit card debt like i think
student loan debt is at 1.5 trillion car
loans are at like 1.3 trillion and
credit cards has never even reached a
trillion i think it's like hovering
between 800 and 900 billion it goes up
that's right that was the that's been
the peak it's been there a couple times
exactly but it hasn't hit a trillion so
it's not that big like the student debt
issue is way worse than the credit card
issue how much is student loan debt
total about 1.5 trillion
okay and then cars 1.3 trillion credit
card hovering between you know 750 850
900 as students are going back zooby
it's kind of interesting united states
sometime next year
it will be official
unless this economy causes people to put
their life on credit cards what's about
to happen is student loan debt is going
to be two times credit card debt
sometime next year it's already closed
if that number on the screen there's
right 1.75 yep i think it's even up from
the last time i checked the stat with
1.5 now it's at 1.7 trillion what this
has gone up
by the way remember how earlier i said i
i wonder how much room is left in credit
so the 16.2 trillion is all mortgages
out on one's credit card right okay
the increase in borrowing which equals
302 billion over the last three months
reflected in higher prices for homes
cars in aggregate consumers still have
plenty of room to spend
with another 3.33 trillion in available
credit
that's a lot of money okay so 3.33
trillion in available credit since the
pandemic started about 42 million new
credit card accounts have been opened
and consumers now hold more than 750
million auto loan credit card mortgage
and home equity line of credit overall
consumer agents 30 to 59 have record
levels of debt
there you go it goes back to the point
you've got to connect those two dots pat
i'm sorry
you have to connect the two dots what
hasn't gone up is wages and so the
delinquency rate regardless of how high
that credit ceiling is as soon as this
delinquency rate starts moving
that's when we're in trouble and that
ceiling's going to come down i'm sorry
go ahead yeah no sorry did you say there
were 750 million
car loans 750 million car mortgage
credit card so it's like all combined
combined so if you run a credit report
and say you got a 28 thousand dollar car
loan you got a 476 thousand dollar
mortgage only you got a nine thousand
dollar credit card debt all of that
they're counting as accounts 750 million
accounts like that so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]